hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to the long-awaited
return of SCP containment breach now
this is updated of 0.7 point 1 and I've
been told numerous times by you lovely
fans that there are new scps new
environments new intro new basically
everything so let's get into it and
explore things for ourselves because it
has been a while since we've been able
to just dive in and eat into something
new so I'm pretty excited about this my
name is markiplier let's do the intro
sequence just to see if there's anything
actually different in this playthrough
the acronym SCP stands for special
containment procedures and the
unofficial motto of the foundation
secure contain protect which sums up
both the goals and methods of the
Foundation's actions dun dun dun I hear
some present Ikki yo dude ok seems kind
of similar so far in that we are back in
the room but that sounds like new music
and that sounded like scp-173 skittering
around out there hello anybody there si
on behalf of the SP blah blah D 1 9 3 4
1 the music is almost calm and serene
what does it all mean hello
those were some really oh hi
I've got some work for you huh please
step out of the cell you got it buddy
Jess follow me we're authorized to kill
any disobedient test subject oh don't
try anything stupid
oh okay big tough guy hey oh well let's
take this job super seriously it's not
like we're all gonna die from an SCP
containment breach haha
ah okay all right way get over here
right now what do you mean it's the
wrong way this is the correct way you
shut up you got it ooh the classy beat
personnel have new things they actually
look like prisoners there's someone up
there
you got it deep voice buddy ass class
T's got a good this is the life to
staring at statues uh-oh there seems to
be a problem with the door control
system the door isn't responding to any
of our attempts to close it so please
maintain direct eye contact with scp-173
hi buddy long time no see
last time I saw you you look
suspiciously like a pony but I'm
assuming that you're gonna be much
better now what this is new did that guy
just get killed cuz I heard a neck
snapping man look at hi hey CP you're
down here buddy you down here buddy
friend Oh huh where is he I hear him
skidding or skittering around but I just
don't know where he is
hi that's where you is I'm getting the
[ __ ] out of here
you screw off that is not where I want
to be right now I apologize for
interrupting whatever you were doing
down there I don't have a gas mask Oh
piss am I supposed to go back down there
and get a gas mask because if so I am in
a lot of trouble hi where are you
these are gas masks on one of these
shelves there better be no thank you
here you go where to go where to go
wiggle wiggle
women okay I'm just gonna have to gun it
through it without gas masks because
obviously I don't have it but he's not
in there so I should be okay right I
should be just fine
oh yeah I'm sure I'll be just fine
mumbles oh so that's what got in my eyes
the last time I'll explain all the toxic
gas okay so things are definitely
looking a lot different they've
definitely changed up just about
everything in this game is that some
sort of electrical subsystem this is a
new environment here they did a lot of
stuff is really cool oh crap this is the
same though isn't it
whoo there's a keycard in here I'll take
that you're in there yeah you're in
there okay you stay in there or how
about I don't know forever that'd be
great and I'll get the hell out of here
all right
what is this SCP oh one - uh-huh
what is ncpo one - I need a higher
security clearance all of this is
basically new they were I didn't open
that door I did not open that door
yeah your water flowing through there
basically this is like so cool okay I'm
gonna I'm gonna check these rooms again
because apparently there are new things
in all these rooms and I still need a
gas mask there's a walkie-talkie I still
need a cask I still need a gas mask this
is absolutely ridiculous they put in a
lot of new stuff hello tiny camera okay
so anyway nothing new in there
I got a walkie-talkie but I guess I get
powered up when did I get a navigator
when did I get a gas mask did I start
with the gas mask oh well that would
have been nice to know a while ago all
right I can't seem to check any of the
channels I don't know how how about the
Navigator okay couldn't connect to now
okay
so basically I'm on my own I am all on
my own
hello Oh familiar room are you in there
good you better not show up freaking a
hole it's actually it's actually really
cool because you know when I got used to
playing this before I you know it got
less scary because I I knew what was
happening in this really dark in here
they updated the textures too on the
walls and that's a really cool good for
them good for them yeah all of this has
been updated this is so cool and if I'm
not mistaken it's a little bit darker oh
[ __ ] no no no no no go up in the door
open the door open the door but no close
the door close the door close
yeah
okay that was a mistake alright let's
just go the other way now whoa what is
this ah crap you got to be kidding me I
don't want to go the maintenance subtle
boy okay so I'm just gonna wha I'm in
for a lot of pain here if I don't hurry
who's bring you bastard friend Brad
he's in the room he's in the room and I
know it I pronounced it room not room
who's this room room is incorrect rum is
correct okay uh you open that door you
[ __ ] okay I gotta remember all my old
techniques like close then close the
door behind me I didn't close the door I
didn't close the dingdong damn door oh
this is not going well
and you'd always close the doors behind
me close the damn door
and I will be fine oh look I'm already
at the old mega warhead silo which means
that I can deactivate the warheads
should i nope I cannot I need a higher
clearance this what is with all these
long rooms
I don't wanna okay got that closed let's
just go we'll be fine
we'll be fine you're not there good
Jesus what is that sound
what is that do I even want to know I do
not
I actually don't so please back oh I'm
gonna go this way
oh wait wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa did I just go backwards I went
backwards yes grass that's why they were
long haul because I went freaking
backwards something idiot hello are you
there now again open up please
open up how could I now know that I was
going back not going backwards I don't
remember seeing this on the way that I
was sprinting from my doom I don't
remember that at all oh I don't remember
it at all Oh aha Wingardium Leviosa
you know the sequel for that came out
today the day I'm recording this for you
it'll be yesterday so go check it out
own Eng Keys Grey's and gallium Livia
song hello ducky hello anomalous duck
you're a bright shining moment on a dark
dark day oh look it's computer man
lettuce I can't even open this I need
you know in the past playthroughs I was
able to find the clockwork machine much
sooner so this is not going well for me
what is that is it a snowflake that's
DNA no that's that's a protein that's a
protein I can see by the spirals it's a
3d designation of a protein oh crap Oh
what the hell
I'm gonna be stuck I got nowhere to go
I got nowhere to go I got nope you shut
up duck
I don't need your cheerful tunes I don't
need anything from you I don't need
anything from none of you I will be fine
happy days ahead
happy days ahead I just got to go back
through the series of long tunnels until
I can get back and then I guess I gotta
go in the maintenance tunnel
I guess just what I wanted to do today
okay he's not there I'm okay I would
live to fight another day I got nowhere
else to go besides the maintenance
tunnels right this was the only way yeah
I came through here yeah it's got to be
so here we go maybe we'll see radical
Larry how we fun haven't seen him since
the update
I haven't seen him since he was a
multicolored pony alright anyway oh look
at that it's dark well what would it be
if it wasn't dark oh okay that just
sounds like water at least 173 isn't
down here it's dark hello door you gonna
open for tab you can open for me come on
okay go down this ah here we go it seems
to be locked well I don't detect any
foreign presences hello thank you come
again
I'm gonna go up you're gonna go to hell
well don't make the elevator go to hell
okay I have made it out unscathed I've
never gone through that thing and not
had something get me the first time that
is unbelievable I my luck might just be
turning around here close the damn door
okay let's see where I am please tell me
that I have some sort of a machine what
is that what is that supposed to be
hi no no you beg off
um purse no now I'm travelers eat him I
want to see you eat him you eat him
enemy of again yes I'm gonna die oh no
that's so unfair that's so unfair you're
sending me in another elevator that's so
unfair
so in forever no now go what happened
what happened what happened are you down
here
you're down here where are you down here
oh we're gonna get high and why is
radical area for me now
am i dead I'm Ben okay that's enough of
that I mean real I'm gonna go away and
cry what the hell did I do to deserve
all of that what did I do
honestly I'm gonna go cry myself to
sleep now
so thanks this is amazing wow I just got
to say wow because basically everything
has been updated it's probably the
biggest update to SCP containment breach
in the entire time I've been playing
this and I've been playing it for a
while I've been playing SCP containment
breach since it was like I don't know
one point two I don't really remember
when I started by started a long time
ago and this is the most significant
change and I loved every second of it
except for when I hate it why did they
both come after me that was not even
remotely fair that was not fair to me or
anyone so anyway thank you all so much
for watching I starting to remember that
nothing really scared me quite like SCP
does it's just like the environment of
everything's out to get you at any
moment anything can kill you just you're
totally boned no matter what that's like
oh man it's just it's it's kind of like
almost a perfect scary game in a lot of
ways but anyway I'm glad that it's
there's so much new stuff that it's
really in reinvigorating it for me and
it's really cool so expect a lot more
parts of this while I explore all the
new scps because I saw two and I didn't
even get to get to him so anyway thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos in I've done
sweating believably so thank you again
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
Oh
good door